the Lajamanu part lies on the gulf of
finland about 70 kilometers east of the
estonian capital Tallinn amid the tracts
of wilderness are historically protected
villages comprised of the wooden houses
once typical of the region in Natori
right by the sea is filming us and Ola
marks weekend getaway a captain's house
originally built in 1902 come on in
welcome the ground floor is a jumble of
small rooms with the living room as the
centerpiece the interiors are a
hodgepodge of rustic and luxurious a
couple searched for five years before
they found the right structure for a
seaside escape it's a blessed to find a
place and you really feel the place was
looking for you too not only you were
looking for a specific place but you
really hear or feel that the place is
calling for you to come here come here
we want you here caret picked out the
wallpaper patterns they were all made in
Finland
I love gold and blue and white these are
really colors I feel connected to and
golden just lifts you up somehow and
there is something Soloman in it and
maybe there is something solemn lean
meat she's a singer and this is where
she works on new songs so many songs
just come to me
when I play this piano and look to the
sea and and it just you know you open up
and songs keep floating to you the
dining room also serves as Gulas office
when they have company they put the two
small tables together
the architect stripped a section of wall
and had the doors restored no not quite
faithfully to the originals we clean the
doors and leave them without paint 100
years ago everybody likes the paint
because paint was expensive paint was
like modern and usually they paint it so
it's a little bit kind of tricky thing
that today we like this kind of wooden
part and we take off the paint
the family bought the house in 2006 and
spent two years overseeing extensive
renovations before they moved in these
kind of foods buildings you'll have
forever we have work forever
it's the kind of living organism they
completely remodeled the upper floor
under the roof the bathroom is up here
downstairs is the children's room and
another guest room one of the laurs
favorite touches is a lamp that he made
himself out of piano wire the kitchen is
next to the living room
everything was modernized except for the
old stove which still serves its
original purpose actually it's the first
kitchen I really designed yeah I like to
cook for my friends and for visitors
because through food I can give
something I can pass something and I can
trust who their health and good salts
and that means a lot to me the couple
both work in Tallinn where they have an
apartment their weekend house in Natori
provides a welcome contrast it's so
different how it's in summertime in
wintertime in springtime all the time
things are different and you feel kind
of like you're flowing time is passing
by here when you are in the city in the
office sitting then everything is same
so it's make you world bigger the house
was built by seafarers and it sits on
two and a half hectares of land the
couple come out here whenever they can
especially in summer when they can sit
outdoors and enjoy the sea view
you